wieder protestierten gestern abend in
mehreren städten tausende menschen gegen
die korona maßnahmen oft blieben die
demonstrationen friedlich doch es kam
auch wieder zu auseinandersetzungen mit
der polizei in mecklenburg vorpommern
protestierten etwa 15.000 menschen an 20
orten versammlungen gab es auch in
rostock in der innenstadt kamen bis zu
4000 menschen zusammen und noch in
berlin zog mehrere aufzüge mit hunderten
teilnehmern durch die straßen wobei so
gegenkundgebungen gab die proteste
fanden den bezirken köpenick zehlendorf
neukölln und mitte statt ein
demonstrationszug ging vom
alexanderplatz zum brandenburger tor
weitere proteste gab es in thüringen
sachsen und sachsen anhalt in leipzig
versammelten sich nach polizeiangaben
rund 300 menschen auf dem augustusplatz
dort liebe es bis auf kleinere
ausschreitungen weitgehend friedlich
anders in bautzen hier wurden polizisten
mit flaschen und steinen beworfen in
dresden wurde am rande der proteste ein
schweizer journalist angegriffen und
verletzt du noch im westen des landes
protestierten maßnahmen gegner in
gummersbach in köln und in lübeck 1000
menschen waren friedlich gegen die
korona beschränkungen unterwegs menschen
die die politik offenbar nicht mehr
erreicht die politikern ohnehin nichts
mehr glauben die sich ausgeschlossen
fühlen aber mit sich mit gewaltsamen
protesten auch selbst ausschließen auch
fdp chef christian lindner gerät in
diesem zusammenhang jetzt in die kritik
dass ungeimpfte vom öffentlichen leben
so gut wie ausgeschlossen sind hätte
nach seinen versprechungen vor der wahl
eigentlich nicht passieren dürfen
gemacht hat er sie gegenüber passanten
festgehalten in einem video das derzeit
auf twitter aber tausendfach geteilt
wird wir schauen mal ran
im job die kinder völlig heißt und
ebenfalls prämiert werden die fdp kommt
ihr denn her wachsen hier sind und hier
sind sie mich da auch muss und dass
ungeimpfte nicht diskriminiert
werden andere von ihnen gehört ja ich
bin nicht der funktion des bv wesel fdp
meine meinung ist in einer gesellschaft
wo so viele gehen kann der ungeimpfte
sich möchten selbst gefährden deshalb
sollen auch im herbst ungeimpfte zb in
die gaststätte gehen können vielleicht
bitte voraussetzung eines negativen
tests denen sie aber nicht bezahlen
müssen das macht die solidargemeinschaft
sagen sie jetzt sagen sie das auch noch
nach den wahlen das sage ich vor den war
nach den wahlen und 2010 haben sie
gesehen dass die fdp nach wien fahren
sogar bereit ist nein zu sagen zu einer
regierung wenn sie dann zu sagen brechen
müsste
tja sagt es vor den wahlen und nach
denen wollen es klingt allerdings anders
versprochen gebrochen was sagen die
eigenen leute aus der fdp zu diesem
video fragen der franziska brandmann sie
ist die vorsitzende der jungen liberalen
hallo verbrannt man
morgen herr brandt man was denken sie
wenn sie dieses video ihres
parteivorsitzenden sehen
ja also ich glaube erst aber müssen sie
christian lindner fragen der würde
natürlich genau diese aussage so hatte
nicht mehr tätigen da bin ich mir sicher
denn ich glaube er würde heute sagen es
muss um verhältnismäßige maßnahmen gehen
wenn ich das video sehe dann denke ich
zurück spricht ja von später im herbst
also dieses video wurde offensichtlich
frühestens im sommer aufgenommen haben
vor über einem halben jahr da aber die
situation noch ein andere da hatten wir
beispielsweise noch keinen omikron da
gab es noch keine berichte über
intensivstation oder sehr nur sehr
vereinzelt in den
lebenswichtige operationen
beispielsweise nicht gemacht werden
konnten bei dieser diese stationen
belegt waren die betten in der
innenstadt zum blickfang durch kugel
patienten also ich denke die situation
hat sich stark geändert hätte christian
lindner das in dem moment gewusst hätte
er sicher eine andere aussage getätigt
das muss man natürlich in dem kontext
dieses videos auch im kontext der zeit
in der das video aufgenommen wurde nicht
sehen aber frau brown waren es ist ja
nichts neues dass ich sage immer wieder
verändert hat das geht seit zwei jahren
so warum werden überhaupt solche
versprechungen dann auch noch vor wahlen
gemacht sie haben auch die bilder der
demonstration gesehen glauben sie dass
das die politikverdrossenheit noch mehr
hat
also ich glaube in der tat dass wir in
den letzten monaten und jahren leider
lernen mussten dass man bestimmte
versprechen nicht mehr machen kann oder
dass man bei solchen versprechen sehr
sehr vorsichtig sein muss wenn die lage
sich stetig ändert ich glaube das haben
wir selber auch persönlich gelernt also
als die korona pandemie begann da weiß
ich noch im märz glaube ich märz 2020 da
hab ich damals noch ein flug den ich
geplant hatte für ein paar monate
erstmal umgebucht weil ich mich hätte
vorstellen können dass wir jetzt zwei
jahre in dieser pandemie stecken ich
glaube wir haben alle da sehr viel
gelernt in der tat müssen wir damit
versprechen vorsichtiger umgehen da bin
ich der festen überzeugung dass solche
grundsätzlich ja darum gehen dass eine
partei bestimmt ist eine bestimmte
priorität setzt und das ist bei der fdp
die priorität der verhältnismäßigkeit
von maßnahmen und das wäre natürlich in
dem video besser gewesen dass in den
fokus zu stellen aber dass man jetzt ein
halbes jahr später kann man das
natürlich gut sagen also ich kann auch
verstehen dass er da in dem moment in
dem er diese aussage in die man dahinter
stand ist auch so gesagt hat
interessanten liegen frau brandt man
auch wenn sie jetzt die
verhältnismäßigkeit ansprechen ihre
partei die fdp steht wie keine andere
partei für freiheit ist diese freiheit
aktuellen gefahren
ich glaube dass freiheit grundsätzlich
immer ein gefahr ist ich glaube das
zeigt uns die geschichte und das zeigt
uns auch international die lage an
anderen anderen orten ich glaube erst
mal dass die freiheit in deutschland
weniger in gefahr ist als in anderen
ländern also beispielsweise wenn man
nach nach hongkong schaut wenn man ihn
nach baku zum beispiel dann leben wir in
einem in einem vergleichsweise freien
land bei ist bei uns rechtsstaatlichkeit
verständliche prozesse gibt demokratie
gibt aber natürlich gibt es ganz
bestimmte freiheiten die
handlungsfreiheit zum beispiel die
bewegungsfreiheit die im rahmen der
kampagne oftmals eingeschränkt wurde und
das ist absolut selbstverständlich viele
gerade das sobald die pandemie
hoffentlich ganz bald hinter uns liegt
wie diese maßnahmen wieder komplett auch
wieder lösen müssen da gibt es ja schon
einige stimmen insbesondere
kretschmann ist mit der gerade ins in
den kopf gestoßen der schon sagt ja man
müsste dann noch mal drüber nachdenken
welche maßnahmen vielleicht
grundsätzlich infrage kommen oder welche
man wieder löst und welche nicht ich bin
der meinung so bald die pandemie hinter
uns liegt müssen alle maßnahmen die im
rahmen der torhunger pandemie getroffen
wurden sofort wieder fallen und das
gehört eben zu diesem gefühl von der fdp
wir müssen unbedingt die
verhältnismäßigkeit von maßnahmen immer
begründen können müssen anstatt sie
sprechen für die jungen liberalen die
pandemie und die korona maßnahmen die
einschränkungen haben vor allem kinder
und auch junge leute ganz extrem
getroffen was sind ihre pläne für diese
gruppe von menschen
also erst einmal glaube ich ist es sehr
wichtig dass bei allen maßnahmen bei
denen das möglich ist gerade kinder von
diesen maßnahmen ausgeklammert werden
weil es kann nicht sein dass gerade zum
beispiel kinder die die bei denen die
eltern sagen sie solle nicht im frieden
zum beispiel vom gesellschaftlichen
leben ausgeschlossen werden aufgrund
dieser entscheidung müsse eltern ich
glaube vor allem dass es kindern ganz
stark ermöglicht werden muss sich sofort
impfen zu lassen wenn sie das möchten
also wir müssen vielmehr impfangebot
konkret an kinder ausrichten bei dir
viel später erst die möglichkeit haben
bekommen kann nicht impfen zu lassen und
wir müssen unbedingt an das thema heran
also es gibt unfassbare viele berichte
von von gesundheitlichen menschen
gesundheitlich trennen die viele junge
menschen davon getragen haben von dieser
pandemie die auf einmal von freiheits
einschränkungen mit
freiheitseinschränkung konfrontiert
wurden die sie sich vorher nie hätte
vorstellen können und deshalb muss die
bundesregierung unendlich wichtig eine
menschliche herz initiative auf den weg
bringen muss zum beispiel daran arbeiten
dass die wartezeiten für psychologische
beratungseinrichtungen ganz stark
verkürzt werden und dass man wenn man
psychische probleme hat und jemand
braucht an dem man sich wenden kann das
dass man da nicht monatelang darauf
warten muss das ist absolut wichtig und
ganz wichtig ist uns wenn maßnahmen
diskutiert werden darauf zu pochen
schulen und bildungseinrichtungen dazu
gehören kindertagesstätten dazu gehören
schulen und universitäten sollen nicht
mehr schließen wenn alle anderen
maßnahmen noch nicht ausgeschöpft wurden
bei es darf nicht weiter das thema
bildung so aufgespart werden als luxus
luxus thema nach dem motto die gastro
ist zwar auf aber die schulen die können
ruhig mal zu machen ein bisschen
bisschen home office viele schüler das
macht ja nichts das macht sehr viel
viele schüler die dann zu hause sitzen
und keine hilfe zu hause bekommen können
haben davon große einschnitte erfahren
und konnten nicht die gleichen
bildungschancen bekommen wie andere
deshalb ist es absolut wichtig dass die
schulen weiter auch bleiben sagt
franziska brandmann die vorsitzende der
jungen liberalen die auch sagt man
sollte nicht versprechungen machen die
man nicht halten kann vielen dank frau
brandt man schon mal genau diesem thema
ist auch bild kolumnist alexander von
schönburg bei uns im studio wir haben es
gehört sie hat gerade gesagt die frau
brandt man hätte vielleicht nicht so ein
versprechen machen sollen christian
lindner an alle ungeimpften ja du hast
es klar gerade gesagt man soll nicht
versprechen machen die man nicht halten
kann das ist natürlich ein wahnsinniges
desaster für die fdp also ich persönlich
muss sagen ich habe genau zweimal fdp
gewählt und beides mal wurde ich bitter
enttäuscht das war einmal 2009 war der
wahlkampf darauf aufgebaut dass man
sagte wir werden steuern senken und das
steuersystem vereinfachen aber vor allem
steuern senken dann kam die fdp mit dem
relativ guten ergebnis in den bundestag
guido westerwelle wurde vize kanzler und
außenminister und damit wurde ihm diese
damit dadurch wurde er gezwungen oder
hat die bittere pille geschluckt auf
diese steuersenkungen zu verzichten das
war das der hauptpunkt der der des
ganzen wahlkampf war wir senken die
steuern das war das letzte mal als die
fdp gewählt haben wir gesagt wir haben
zehn jahre gewartet er auch diesmal
werde ich die fdp noch einmal wählen
weil sie kam mir vor und das verhalten
hat sie auch den ganzen wahlkampf so
kommuniziert wir sind die partei die
gegen die übergriffig kite des staates
der bremsklotz sind und immer gut wenn
die fdp in die regierung kommen und die
wird wenn ich das so klar sagt wird die
das schon machen und schon wieder ist es
ist unfassbar also für mich ist die fdp
jetzt für jahrzehnte bestehen matti
siert als die umfaller partei als die
partei die das was sie im wahlkampf sagt
ab dass man sich überhaupt nicht
verlassen kann also das war also es ist
auch eine energische schamlosigkeit
dabei wirklich von von von das war ja
nicht dieses eine video ist ja nur ein
feel eines von vielen beispielen sie
könnten jetzt beide könnten jetzt
beispiel aus talkshows bringen wir
könnten beispiele aus wahlkampfreden
bringen es war immer wieder die gleiche
musik wie ihr die fdp werden dafür
sorgen dass die dass die rechte auch von
ungeimpften geachtet werden frau brandt
man hat aber die verhältnismässigkeit
angesprochen hat denn da so ein bisschen
in schutz genommen hat gesagt es war
eben vor ein paar wochen vor ein paar
monaten ist das video alt ist schon eine
zeitlang her jetzt ist die gegebenheiten
die sind anders kannst du es
nachvollziehen selbstverständlich kann
ich das nachvollziehen aber ich muss
sagen insgesamt fand ich die einordnung
von verbrannt man am selig ehrlich
gesagt ist bleibt dabei das ganz klare
versprechen gemacht worden sind und
diese versprechen
zweieinhalb minuten nach der wahl
absolut
harmlos und einfach gebrochen da musst
du dich beiden vereinen versprechen
zurückhaltend wie gesagt ist wie damals
bei den steuererhöhungen dann baut eine
als steuersenkungen dann baue deinen
wahlkampf auf andere dinge auf und sagte
gegen ihn und ziemlich von ort zu ort
von wahlkampf zur wahlkampfveranstaltung
von talkshow zu talkshow und verspricht
etwas um es dann sofort nach der wahl zu
brechen also die fdp ist mich auf
jahrzehnte hinaus und wählen war ich
habe es wie gesagt vor zehn jahren von
knapp sieben jahre war etwa zehn jahren
gewählt die haben ihre versprechen
schamlos gebrochen diesmal wieder ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass die fdp
dieses stigma je wieder los wird nun ist
das wesen der politik kompromisse zu
machen alexander alle drei andere
parteien mussten abstriche machen sonst
kommt man eben einfach nicht zusammen in
der politik die grünen haben
beispielsweise aus tempolimit verzichtet
um nur einen punkt zu nennen die fdp
konnte sich in einigen entscheidenden
punkten durchaus auch durchsetzen also
es muss hier ein geben und nehmen sein
sonst kommt man nicht in der politik
zusammen selbstverständlich aber die
grünen haben nicht ihren wahlkampf
darauf aufgebaut dass sie ein tempolimit
durch durchbringen wollen sondern den
ganzen ganzen fächer von
versprechungen gehabt die fdp hat nun
wirklich geworben als die
bürgerrechtspartei die in dieser in
dieser in dieser lage wo wir seit zwei
jahren darüber reden dass der staat
immer wieder übergriffig wird dass der
staat immer wieder seine kompetenzen
ausweitet in einer notlage das ist mir
vollkommen klar aber die fdp hat sich
eindeutig positioniert als die blockade
gegen die bg gegen die übermäßige über
griffigkeit des staates und ganz
explizit auch immer gesagt auch es muss
dann recht sein auch als ungeimpfter die
menschenwürde ist unangreifbar auch als
ungeimpfter bist du ein
vollständiger staatsbürger mit vollem
recht oder auch wirklich tritt artikel 1
des grundgesetzes zu also die fdp hat
darauf schon ihren wahlkampf aufgebaut
also ist nicht einfach ein kleiner
kompromiss und er sagt er noch immer was
besonders peinliches an diesem interview
dass er dann noch mal sagt jahr 2017
haben sie ja gesehen 2017 sind wir
bereiten für unsere prinzipien sogar
darauf zu verzichten in regierung zu
gehen es ist nun ziemlich in die hose
gegangen wir werden gleich mit an die
scheuer dem ehemaligen csu
verkehrsminister noch darüber sprechen
der ihn einen lügner nennt und als
pinocchio gezeichnet hat vielen dank
alexander für eine einordnung und war
wir bei corona sind schauen wir mal
meine damen und herren auf die aktuellen
corona zahlen das ist heute ganz
interessant denn mittlerweile liegen
eigentlich wieder zahlen vor den man
auch trauen kann das rk die hat die
nachmeldungen die über die
weihnachtsfeiertage
liegengeblieben waren mit einbezogen
jetzt also die aktuelle zahl der
neuinfektionen liegt bei 45
1690 vor einer woche waren es noch
30.000 also das wäre ein riesensprung
aber wie gesagt das liegt vor allem auch
daran dass jetzt also die nachmeldungen
mit hereingekommen sind die aktuelle
sieben tage incidents liegt bei 300
87,9 gestern waren es 375 7 da ist also
nur ein kleiner anstieg zu sehen wir
schauen mal auf die hotspots das ist
ganz interessant und da sind wir vor
allem das im norden hier wir sehr rote
gebiete haben und am ältesten sozusagen
es ist auf der kleinen nordseeinsel sylt
der luxusinsel der deutschen da liegt
die inzidenz momentan bei über
1.500 das ist eine der 16 fachen seit
weihnachten 500 inselbewohner sind
derzeit in quarantäne
die gastronomie schließt kneipen
restaurants
machen zu und auslöser soll eine
weihnachtsfeier in einem nobel club
gewesen sein bei dem sich zahlreiche
gäste mit gefälschten pässen
eingeschlichen hatten dass also die
situation auf sylt und dann schauen wir
noch mal auf die hospitalisierung rate
dir wichtig ist
3271 insgesamt im moment auf
intensivstationen davon 2000 knapp über
atmet 1200 nicht beatmet und hier sehen
wir noch mal die situation in
deutschland große unterschiede auch hier
auch wenn die infektionszahlen im norden
beispielsweise sylt hier sehen ist ein
bisschen besser in grau höher waren ist
die zahl der die hospitalisierung rate
dort deutlich niedriger als
beispielsweise in bayern das also die
aktuelle situation jetzt mit validen
zahlen mit zahlen die wieder sinn machen
nach dem ja wir sozusagen über die
weihnachtsfeiertage in ein daten
blindflug gewesen sind